اليوم ، قصة الصفحة الأولى في نيويورك
تايمز تشير إلى أن استطلاعات الرأي والمقابلات الأخيرة
تظهر أن العديد من الروس
يتجمعون الآن حول فلاديمير بوتين الذي
ينضم إلي الآن هو إيفان نشابورينكو ، وهو
مراسل بمكتب موسكو
في نيويورك تايمز وهو يعمل حاليًا
خارج اسطنبول وهو يشاركه الخط الثانوي.
في القصة التي تحمل عنوان اهتزت في
البداية ، يتجمع العديد من الروس الآن وراء
غزو بوتين ،
لقد كتبت أنت وزملاؤك هذا تقول ، بعد
خمسة أسابيع
من غزو الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين لأوكرانيا ، هناك
دلائل على أن الصدمة الأولية للجمهور الروسي
قد أفسحت المجال لمزيج  من الدعم
لقواتهم والغضب من الغرب ،
فما غير ما حدث
جيدًا عندما بدأ الغزو للتو ،
كان على الناس أن يختاروا
إما دعمه أو عدم دعمه ، فقد
كانت هناك معركة على عقول الناس
في روسيا والدولة-  كان تشغيل
الدعاية يعمل بكامل قوته للتأكد من أن
العديد من الأشخاص ينضمون إلى
الجانب المهزوم من الرئيس قدر الإمكان ويبدو
أنه  لقد نجحوا حتى الآن والعديد من
الذين عارضوا الحرب
إما غادروا أو واجهوا أه تعرف أه
محاكمة جنائية حقًا لأن
الأشخاص الذين خرجوا في الأيام الأولى
من الغزو تم اعتقالهم بوحشية
وحكم على العديد منهم
اعتقالات إدارية لذلك
أظهرت الحكومة بوضوح
حدود سلطتها وتجاوزت ما
فعلته من قبل لتتأكد من أن الكثير من الناس
يؤيدون الحرب أو على الأقل يقولون
إننا ندعم الحرب نحن بحاجة لجعل
هذا التحذير أه عندما يكون مستطلع الرأي  يتصل بك
في روسيا ويسألك عما إذا كنت
تؤيد ما إذا كنت تكرر ما إذا كنت
تؤيد
الحرب وإذا أه تقول
لا وهذا الجواب قد أه تعرف أه
يرفع ضدك محاكمة جنائية أه
إذن أه أعتقد أن معظم الناس
سيقولون أنهم يفعلون ذلك  دعم الحرب حتى لو
اعتقدوا خلاف ذلك